as i have already emphasized the
strategic framework is deliberately
cautious at this stage
but i want to be clear that in the
coming weeks if the data allows and
positive trends continue
we will seek to accelerate the easing of
the restrictions however the framework
today provides detail on what as
of now we expect our next changes to be
firstly it confirms that if all goes
according to plan
we will move fully back to a level
system from the last week in april
at that stage we hope that all parts of
the country currently
in level four will be able to move out
of level four
and back initially to level three
possibly with some revision to the
content of the levels
and afterwards to levels depending on
incidence and prevalence
of the virus at that time the advantages
of the level system of course is that it
will allow us to let some parts of the
country move
faster than others if the data supports
that
moving back to the variable level system
at that time will also be contingent on
us
having vaccinated all jcvi priority
groups one to nine which as i said
earlier
we hope to have done by mid-april that
matters not only because these groups
will be more protected but also because
we believe
that vaccinating around half of the
population will have a significant
effect on reducing transmission
across society as a whole and although
we don't yet know exactly how big an
effect that will be we do hope and
believe
it will give us the head room to
carefully ease restrictions
is therefore from the last week of april
that we would expect to see
phased but significant reopening of the
economy
including non-essential retail
hospitality and services like gyms and
hairdressers
and of course the more of us who are
vaccinated and the more we all stick by
the rules
now the faster that safe pace is likely
to be if we all stay in this together
our progress will be greater
you